[Música]
escopetas utilizadas para reprimir a los
manifestantes que han salido a las
calles desde la muerte de maxa Mini el
16 de septiembre en Irán amnistía
internacional Calcula que al menos 20
manifestantes han muerto entre ellos
tres adolescentes luego de ser
alcanzados por disparos de escopeta
entre las víctimas mortales está jadis
nacida y adolfacial avinesade muchos
otros resultaron heridos a veces incluso
quedaron ciegos
las escopetas pueden ser utilizadas por
la policía en algunos casos para
controlar las multitudes Estas armas
pueden considerarse no letales O al
menos menos letales que las armas
militares Como por ejemplo los fusiles
de asalto cuando se utilizan a una
distancia segura y con munición especial
con perdigones de plástico pero en la
manifestaciones de Irán han sido
utilizadas de manera muy diferente las
escopetas son utilizadas por todas las
unidades de las fuerzas de seguridad
iraníes policías antidisturbios policías
vestidos de civil y también por miembros
de la milicia de la guardia
Revolucionaria de balish obtuvimos una
entrevista poco común se trata de un
miembro del Valencia que participó en la
represión de las manifestaciones en la
ciudad del norte de Irán lo llamaremos
mostaza por razones de confidencialidad
no vamos a escuchar su voz pero
transcribimos sus palabras en nuestra
unidad tenemos escopetas
gases lacrimógenos
de porras
pistolas de paintball
y pistolas aturdidoras
tuvimos unas horas de entrenamiento en
lo que llamamos armas no militares como
estas aprendimos Qué armas debemos
utilizar y En qué situaciones pero
nuestro entrenamiento no sirvió para
nada las manifestaciones en la vida real
no tienen nada que ver con nuestro
entrenamiento
en nuestros entrenamientos nos decían
que debíamos disparar al suelo si
estábamos demasiado cerca del objetivo
pero nadie hace eso en las
manifestaciones intento no importar a
los manifestantes disparo al suelo en
otras direcciones para ahuyentarlos pero
no todos son como yo los miembros de mi
unidad le apuntan a la gente para
impactarla en el pecho o en la cabeza
para matarla lanzamos un llamado a unas
redes sociales pidiéndole a los
manifestantes iraníes que nos enviaron
sus fotos de las municiones usadas
recuperadas en las manifestaciones
recibimos más de 100 fotos y videos de
30 manifestaciones diferentes en
distintas ciudades de Irán en las
imágenes se ven Rastros de granadas de
gas lacrimógeno balas de caucho también
de plástico y también balas disparadas
por kalas
también se recuperó munición de escopeta
de calibre 12 en los cartuchos con
componentes fabricados por la empresa
Franco italiana chefdith Pero la
munición más frecuentemente recuperada
fue esta un cartucho de escopeta
transparente con la palabra mahama 12 y
las palabras
antidisturbios rbc duro o blando una de
las fotos que recibimos muestra Incluso
un cartucho sin usar después de que los
manifestantes redujeran a un miembro de
las fuerzas de seguridad de la ciudad de
[__] se ven las bolas de plástico de
color naranja rojizo en su interior y
según mostaza el basic estos cartuchos
antidisturbios de fabricación iraní son
estándar pero sus unidades también
habrían recibido cartuchos de escopeta
con balines metálicos
los cartuchos etiquetados como blandos
tienen balines más grandes en su
interior son dolorosos pero no son
mortales y se evita disparar a la cara y
a los ojos los perdigones duros son más
pequeños los cartuchos contienen una
gran cantidad de balines duros
[Música]
también recibimos cartuchos de colores
que no son necesariamente para usos
antidisturbios no están marcados y
contienen principalmente pequeños
balines últimamente recibimos cada vez
más cartuchos de estos cuando uno
dispara con eso se destruye el objetivo
han visto las fotos de personas
asesinadas con fusiles de cazas tienen
pequeñas heridas por todo el cuerpo de
estas pequeñas bolas de metal si uno
impacta un pájaro con esos balines de
metal es mortal si uno impacta a una
persona puede cegarla o paralizarla no
importa lo que tenga escrito si es un
cartucho antidisturbios o un cartucho la
carpeta es lo mismo si se dispara corta
distancia puede matar el uso de munición
o proyectil múltiple está prohibido por
directrices de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas sobre armas a menos de
Tales este documento Establece que el
disparo de múltiples proyectiles al
mismo tiempo resulta impreciso y en
general no puede cumplir con los
principios de necesidad y también de
proporcionalidad
los perdigones de metal como los que se
disparan con escopetas nunca deberían
usarse los manifestantes también nos
enviaron fotos de las heridas causadas
por las armas no letales contusiones
causadas por vales de plástico y heridas
causadas por pérdidas metálicos el New
York Times afirma que cientos de
manifestantes iraníes han quedado ciegos
mostaza el pasillo nos explicó que este
año únicamente los guardias
revolucionarios y los agentes de la
policía están autorizados a utilizar
armas como los fusiles de asalto también
nos dijo que no ha utilizado antes estas
calas unicoff A menos por ahora
También tenemos escalas nicops en
nuestros cuarteles todavía no hemos
recibido la orden de utilizarlas pero lo
haremos cuando se dé la orden
[Música]